other news here tonight Vegas hit some
record highs for home prices last year
and now mortgage rates are hovering
around seven percent right now so what
does this mean for first-time home
buyers and could it indicate a possible
housing crash in the way 8 news now
reporter Ryan Matthey taking those
questions to the most visited Real
Estate website in the country
is settling in three beds two and a half
baths in North Las Vegas you're talking
putting offers in sight unseen there'd
be like 26 offers a Triumph after first
looking for a home in 2019 when interest
rates were lower but at the time she
thought they were too high I kicked
myself for doing that because obviously
I would have been able to get more house
or had a less of a house payment
compared with her first go-round and
even with a mortgage rate twice as high
now she still had to fight multiple
offers to get in here Zillow says
competition like that is necessary
though to help stabilize the market
after record highs hit last year in Las
Vegas is experiencing a much needed
rebalancing Market rebalancing orfe
devonji is a senior Economist for Zillow
their data ranks Vegas number five for
steepest home value drops Nationwide
homeowners saw that homes appreciate
roughly 43 percent from the start of the
pandemic and so that increase was
clearly unsustainable even so the most
recent Las Vegas Realtors report shows a
bounce back from last month medium
prices for homes condos and Townhomes
are up slightly with over 4 500 units
available throughout the valley but it's
all a far cry from this time last year
when record highs were hit median home
prices forty thousand dollars more than
today condos and Townhomes ten thousand
more homeowners uh sitting on Rick
record low monthly costs are deciding
not to sell they don't want to trade a
low monthly payment for you know today's
seven percent mortgage rates the high
home equity what he says averts a
housing crash for now instead he says
it's a waiting game to sell that slow
price adjustment is going to help many
first-time home buyers uh come back in
the market